Joanne and New Mexico starts off this
hour hi Joanne how are you hi I'm great
good what's up all right I live about 25
miles outside of Gallup and my fiancee
and I own a full trailer and an RV we
have no debt and we're just trying to
actually be able to afford and be able
to get out of the situation on what
situation the situation of living out
here it he spending so much time working
for this guy on his ranch and not
getting any money out of it or anything
so we're just barely surviving and we're
going to deal with food fans and that
kind of thing so you have a career
crisis yes
so Wade you're correct so when's he
going to get another job that is the
question especially living 25 miles
outside of town and not having a running
vehicle his transmission went out on his
RV and it's just like RV is your only
vehicle the RV is the only vehicle right
now we were in Quartzsite Arizona which
was even worse than this actually in a
lot of ways and we got out of there and
the transmission went out out here and
we're not able to get out please it hurt
a lot so what is the RV worth if the
transmission was fixed less than $800
so you're saying are you living in the
RV we're living in the RV and the pole
trailer we've it's two people and with
all the stuff that been accumulated over
time there's just no way of getting rid
of both of them one has to be for
storage and the other is to live in but
at least we don't have a debt on it
that's a good start
um well I mean what does he make well
he's actually been working on a motion
generator of sorts because we don't even
have any power out here and what I say
man what is his income oh there is no
income unfortunately like I said we're
just barely surviving out you're on on
food stamps and such and what does it
take to fix that I thought you said he
was working on someone's ranch Ian's
working on the ranch but he doesn't make
any money doing it basically it's he
works on the ranch for to be able to
park here and stay here and that's all
that's all I mean it's just for rent
okay works 40 hours a week to be able to
rent a piece of ground yep
and unfortunately we can't move the RV
out of here because the transmission is
out what are you talking to me on I am
talking to you on a government provided
free cell phone Wow okay um you have any
family I have family unfortunately my
mom is in the assisted living care
facility you have any more they can give
you guys a leg up to get you towards
town because you gotta get I mean you
you've got to get to where you can make
an income and that that's what we've
been wanting to do in fact that was why
we left quartzite was because we wanted
to we want a dream or somewhere where
you were working just to live on the
land if you want to go make an income
because the transmission that you
stopped for the transformation went out
yeah basically the the we could feel the
transmission slipping you know and we
happen to be in Gallup itself and if the
transmission had gone out there there
was nowhere to stay and we did not have
money it's like something like it would
have been like about $1,000 Turkish mine
a place come on
well the thing can you limp it into town
I don't even think that we could do that
and if we did make it to town then it
would be a it would be gone it would be
towed and we'd have no way of getting in
and out I want you to sell it I want you
to get you a dinky but little car and
then get into town and start making some
money and get you a little apartment
that would mean that we would have that
you have to get out of there yeah this
is not working it's not even close to
working no you have to get out of there
like your tails on fire your slaves you
have to pack up and leave town and go to
a metropolitan area where you can get
work you have to leave
Charlie option and I don't know if you
leave the thing behind and you walk out
I don't know if you get it started and
you limp it into town and sell it for up
to 300 bucks or something and use that
to get you know to get on into town some
other way but you know get on a bus and
go and I don't know what crap you got in
that trailer but it didn't worth spit
you're living on food stamps talking to
me on a government cell phone and the
guys working for no money at all zero
money literally he is working for the
ability to keep his RV on the guy's land
you know this is going nowhere fast
you guys have to break this cycle and
you got to get excited about breaking
this cycle and that's your only shot it
might be to that you reach out to a
church in an area and they might get you
a bus ticket to get you out of there in
a metro area but get into where humans
are where there's work where people pay
you money for working and you know that
this dream or whatever it is of living
on a ranch is a bad dream it didn't
working for you at all you've got to
break this cycle it's all I know to tell
you do kiddo but I'll tell you what if I
was in that situation I would be busting
out of there if I had to walk out I'd
walk out
are something going to move I'm not
going to sit in this situation and hope
it gets better it's not going to get
better until you do something about it
you